on dit que les murs ont des oreilles
ceux de chambord raconte toute
l'histoire du château
celle qui est gravé au coeur de la
pierre tendre de tuffeau par les
visiteurs de passage
le graphique qui devient objet
scientifique
c'est un patrimoine parce que on à la
trace évidemment du passage de tous ses
visiteurs et ses hôtes du château on a
des pensées philosophiques des
références à des événements politiques
en france et dans le monde
donc on comprend tout l'intérêt de les
étudier et l'oeil exercé de virginie
révèle bien des surprises
les bateaux des mariniers qui
transportait les pierres les marques
détacheront et le tournage du film peau
d'âne en 1971 en 1825 victor hugo lui
même
imprime sa marque dans le mur en
visitant l'édifice lui aussi a voulu
signer a voulu marquer son passage à
chambord alors il le dit d'ailleurs dans
une lettre qu'il a graphite est ici en
on a cherché longtemps son graffiti et
puis on la trouvait en fait dans cet
escalier qui mène au logis de françois
1er dans un recoin sombre au bas d'un
escalier un autre message gravé indique
que le château fut en danger il date en
fait de 1945 est fait référence
directement à un événement qui a eu lieu
à chambord c'est un feu qui a ravagé en
fait la tour dans laquelle nous sommes
après des travaux de soudure les
pompiers sont intervenus et ils ont
laissé la trace de leur passage et de
leur sauvetage
donc on peut lire un papier de blois à
chambord est venu ici le jour du feu
enfin dans cette pièce ouverte
exceptionnellement lors des journées du
patrimoine c'est un véritable décor
effectué à la mine de plomb par des
domestiques
ici c'était le service de
l'eschansonnerie
de son épouse qui soit l'objet soit
travaillé et ils ont décoré cet espace
de vie et de travail leur on y voit des
châteaux imaginaire salamandre des plats
de service du xviie c'est une pièce que
l'on a re découvert il ya quelques
années est tout à fait intéressante sur
les murs de chambord on rencontre les
gourmands les philosophes les poètes les
amoureux les monarchistes et les
républicains un mode d'expression se
mélangent toutes les histoires de france